l'enfant du pays brise dixon nous vient
tout droit de campagne à l'eau médecin
j'étais trouver un autre rôle un petit
rôle mais c'est quoi ce rôle c'est pas
enfin c'est plutôt comme un genre de
réunion ce sera purement professionnel
fais moi confiance d'accord je dois
quitter la ville et toute façon je
t'envoie toutes les confirmations de
désinvolture pampa règne en enfer
d'élèves et jeté un
sérieux donc ça c'est ce qu'ils admirent
ouais elle est géniale
et wissous essonne
on parle que de vous dans notre petite
ville
bienvenue à la maison
[Musique]
ora
oui les amis sûr je suis vraiment design
j'ai loué un jet ce matin juste pour
venir te voir je vais te reconquérir ma
belle super
si toutes ces personnes sont des amis
pourquoi ne pas leur dire la vérité qu
on n'est pas ensemble
le coeur a ses raisons que la raison
ignore j'ai fait une erreur c'est pour
cette raison que les agents ne sortent
pas avec leurs clients et moi je n'ai
pas mon mot à dire je sais qu on fait
juste semblant pour qu'un quand on est
tous les deux je me sens bien
cette photo vous du départ et sur les
maisons quoi
[Musique]
mais ça
et certaines qu'on n'est pas en train de
faire une on doit pas toujours ce pays
où règne
[Musique]